hey how's it going this is Craig Cannon
and you're listening to Y Combinator's
podcast
today's episode is with Henry Cooper
gross and a new harihar on Anna's
partner here at YC and Henry K is the
co-founder of Breck's Breck's provides
corporate credit cards for startups and
they went through YC in the winter 2017
batch and just closed their Series B
which was led by YC continuity so in
addition to discussing how the Breck's
team built out their service on you and
Henry Kay also cover the specifics of
what it takes to build a fin tech
startup in 2018 and Henry K shares
advice for young founders because he
started his first company at 16 all
right here we go hi everyone I'm Anu a
partner at YC continuity and we have
Enrique here who's the founder of
Breck's which was a YC winter 17 company
the exciting news about praxis they're
actually launching soon and they offer
corporate credit cards they're basically
redefining how corporate credit cards
work for startups so very excited to
have Enrique here and we collette start
a little bit about your background we
obviously at YC have known you for a
very long time
both you and Pedro and you guys started
you know your first FinTech startup when
you we're at the ages of 15 and 16 which
is not you know something we see every
day so can you tell us a little bit
about what was the first company you
found it and then how did you find your
path to Y Combinator yeah for sure so
first thanks for having me here
yeah and so Peter and I we both we both
started coding pretty early I think that
was super helpful I think that was a
little bit lucky ah how early was that
so I was started when I was 12 because
it was this game in one way it was like
a paid game and my parents I want to pay
it for me and I figured I have learn how
to code I could play for free mm-hmm
and Pedro like nobody knows how he
started coding but he started coming
when he was like nine years old and then
doing our teenage years we did a lot of
like interesting things so I
participated in building this emulator
for this game and I learned a lot of how
to code it because of that and like
build like a version of that game pedra
on the other hand when he was 12 he
found like the first jailbreak for the
iPhone 3G which got like a lot of
attention and so we had doing our
teenagers a bunch of like experiences
already in tech that led us to believe
it's possible to start a company so for
me it was that I was working at this
startup and did the founder I thought it
was like a really cool guy and my
thought was like if he can do it I can
do it too and then ice tried to start an
education company and that didn't work
out and then I met Pedro in the end of
2012 basically fighting on Twitter
programming text editors vim verse Emacs
and I was when he was Emacs and I won
and we basically became super friends
and decided to start a company together
which was Pagar me it was like a payment
processor online payment processor down
in Brazil I think the comparables here
would be like something like stripe or
Braintree or we pair like those kind of
companies and we grew that company from
to a pretty reasonable size it was like
a really good experience and you raised
only $300,000 yeah it wasn't by option
that much at that point so we were 15
and 16 when we started a company so it's
not like a lot of people in Brazil were
willing to give us much more than that
mm-hmm and then after we raised the
money we were like oh this is so much
money like we can do whatever we want of
this and we were lucky back payments in
Brazil it's in terms of margin a better
business than most of the world mm-hmm
so we were able to have a profitable
company since I think the end of the
first year okay that's that was super
helpful because then we just grew with
our own profits we didn't have the need
to to fundraise and profit self a lot of
problems if you can have them that's
true and you sold the company
four years later when your team size was
around
yeah so we grew to company I feel the
stats but the time we sold it we're
doing a little bit over 1.5 billion and
transaction volume we have I think a
little bit over a hundred people I think
110 115 something like that and we sold
it September 16 so that was probably
like three years and a half almost four
years not a lot of people have built a
hundred people team and they're less
than twenty why did you sell it a couple
reasons um we always thought that
programming it could be a big business
but it couldn't be something I think as
big as our ambition because I don't
think we had a lot of edge
internationally so Brazil is a pretty
big market for payments you can see like
pucks a girl just IP owed four nine
billion dollars but I didn't think we
had enough edge to go international we
wanted to build a global company and he
got got it into Stanford also mm-hmm so
we're kind of curious to see how that
went
Sanford always gets you yeah exactly it
was my dream soon with 14 to go to
Stanford right so it's kind of like that
and I remember you know right from your
application base one year into Stanford
you guys had applied to YC with actually
an augmented reality startup and by the
time you graduate it from YC that's how
the you know you launched Brax
or you were working on the Breck's idea
hadn't launched yet can you talk a
little bit about like how that
transition happened you know you coming
from AR as an idea and then saying no
you know we are gonna work on the
corporate redefining the corporate
credit card experience yeah for sure
um so after we got a Stanford we're like
we're not gonna do payments anymore fin
tag too complicated you know if there's
like old banks you know like that's
we're not gonna do that anymore like
we've been through that yeah we're gonna
do something new something easier and
then we tie a are was easier definitely
not and then we started thinking about
this ideas etc and then it was actually
three months into Stanford that we
decided that we wanted to apply to YC
and we applied
and we got into two 2yc of this AR idea
and then a few weeks in or like okay
this is complicated like we don't know
anything about hardware we don't know
anything about optics like we can't we
could only build the software but like
if Apple killed an API or Google killed
an API like then the business would be
ruined you know like this all these
things that we started to think about
and we're like okay that's not what we
want to do so then we were like in this
limbo and we're super worried is OSHA we
took YC money shall we give it back leg
is that something that we should do and
we talked to purchase like no no go
figure out something and I'm like okay
and then we started thinking about
things we wanted to do we went through
like a bunch of ideas and then we went
back for an idea we thought for a long
time we're like impo Garmin we were a
payment system right so we received the
money and then we paid out the DDD
merchants and we're like well why do I
need to pay out the merchants why can I
just pay out the suppliers directly
right or the employees why can't I be
like and we started grasping this idea
of what are the b2b financial services
that we can generate value right and we
actually thought about creating a bank
the creating a bank is very complicated
as we went to find out in the and then
we were like especially in the u.s.
especially in the US yeah
so we went and said okay let's do a
product of a bank then all these
products are super it's pretty good
right and then we looked at credit cards
that seemed like a 1 on the product but
we didn't actually go too deep into it
and then but we kind of had this
landscape of like b2b financial products
who are kind of looking and then we
wanted to get a corporate credit card
like ourselves and that was kind of it
and then we were talking to one YC
partner Dalton who also said hey all
these startups they have a lot of
trouble getting corporate credit cards
they're like okay let's investigate that
and then figured out that one we
couldn't get one mm-hmm
why because well because like they
wanted us we went there and they're like
well you don't have any financial
history I was like but I have $120,000
mm-hmm like that's a lot of money might
be yeah wizzy like you can just give me
$5,000 in limit I'll be fine there's
like no we won't give you it unless your
personal guarantee but
didn't have FICO score because we'd had
just moved to the US mm-hmm so we
couldn't personally guarantee the card
and then we went to talk to like a lot
of our batch mates in like a few of them
were like oh yeah I can get a card all
no none of the international ones could
get a heart and the other ones a lot of
people chose not to get a car because
like they didn't want to personally
guarantee the card mm-hmm because as I
agree with them like the whole point of
building a corporation is not having
like personal liability attached to it
right so there is all these people who
just using debit cards and like just
walking around of debit cards of
$120,000 in the bank or just using their
personal cards and log all these things
that okay that has to be in the phishing
like it has to be a better way to do
this and then that's kind of like how
Brett's came to be like by seeing that
problem of our batch mates and ourselves
not being able to get a corporate credit
card or having two personal garyun see
it we had the idea of building something
better so let's talk about the team
right one of you know you guys launched
you launched recently but you've been
there for 18 months or now and so how
when you launched Breck's during YC and
right after demo day how big was the
team and can you also talk about your
first 10 employees like how did you hire
them and how did you decide who they
would be yeah sure I think one thing
that we really believe everybody says
that is the employees that impress
employees gonna set a foundation for
later and I think that we really took
that to heart when if I'll we got our
first tenant so in programming we didn't
have a lot of options in the first ten
so we just got the smartest people we
know there was even this guy who didn't
know how to code at all but he was like
a physics Olympics champion like well
physics seems pretty card coding I think
is easier than physics so we might as
well just hire him and teach him how to
code right so hire like a people that we
we knew that weirdest martes and we just
like made it work
I'm Brett's hitting we were a little bit
more targeted we were like okay
those people were really good and
they're doing really well now but like
if I could do it the right way from the
beginning what would I do
and our first two hires were actually
like a CFO and a general
general counsel oh wow I would have
never you know I know that now because
we know you guys but like I know most
startups are not hiring a CFO and a GC
yeah exactly because going with that the
thing about getting a really good
partner and being able to rebuild
everything from scratch and having like
the good blow and all that having a
staff that like we're still young right
we're a 2221 so it's not like we're
older but like not that old so when we
go to Bank having people who are more
experienced than you are and having them
be the people that actually help you
like do the plan and describe everything
is really really valuable and we were
very generous of the officers and the
packages for these people because we
really believe it could like change the
way the business wins so we got and well
let me ask you this it is very hard for
I found that this early to be able to
hire a really credible GC in a CFO right
no matter even if the offer of the
package is attractive because they you
know they're probably they probably have
multiple options so how did you get them
over the line to believe in your mission
and join Bragg's so I think this is a
little bit of the advantage of being a
second time founder is that I think
people who are experienced they want to
work with other people who are
experienced so that helped I think my do
you guys came from Brazil yeah so I
think that basically so usually founders
they have this right like they have this
first product mm-hmm and that may or may
not have product market fit but they
have a stake and then they has this like
long-term vision and they that's like
very very far away mm-hmm and they
usually don't have the plan in between
that much I think these like more
executive level hires they want to
understand better to plan in between I
think that's is something we had really
well defined since early on is like okay
we're starting with like this credit
card for startups which is if I think
it's a great market like and then we
have this big long term vision how do we
get from here to there mm-hmm I think
making that very clear and like how they
could like how they would be the
difference between getting they're not
getting they're also like if they could
add a lot of value there was something
that I think got them across the line
so I remember specifically or VAR GC we
were talking about how in order to be
able to scale a lot we would do a lot of
the regulatory things he didn't do in
his last company and we would do it
right this time here and how that would
change like this is part of the plan to
actually work versus other companies
that failed like that got him really
excited because okay I learned so much
for the experience now I wanted to pop
the opportunity to make it right right
mm-hmm
right so I think that's how I got across
the line but also having a really strong
set of investors helps a lot being able
to get where they need on cash like a
lot of times people will want people to
take huge pay cuts we were never at that
type we always was pretty generous in
cash like those kind of things got it
and then so they really they were your
third and fourth hire talk about this
next six so who are they and where did
they come from
um so we didn't have an easy time
recruiting most companies don't yeah
because we were from Brazil so it's not
like we knew a bunch of people people
say oh what about your Stanford
networker it's like I was there for
three months in my networks all freshman
so at least it's not like I knew a ton
of people yeah there were gonna be class
of 2020 I remember exactly I was gonna
be class of 2020 so maybe in 2020 I have
a bunch of people I can hire but it was
really tough for us um we basically
started skewing towards people that were
somewhere to us in some sense because
it's what we could so we got a bunch of
international folks yeah so I think our
first engineer was yn and then you know
we got a French dude and we imported
someone from Brazil I think we just did
whatever we needed to do here first ten
but we didn't we didn't lower our like
we didn't have a quality bar that was
lower because of that we're still had
like okay these two are really strong
they come came from really good
companies so if I'm stripe
and okay how do we keep that bar up
mm-hmm
maybe and we didn't hire a lot waiting
to find the right people and that paid
off mm-hmm so you are slow at building
the team versus trying to get the first
end quickly yeah yeah and how was your
interview process especially when you
were trying to hire someone from Brazil
or why or these different locations like
how did you actually test for that
quality bar so we actually brought them
here okay so not we we didn't interview
them remotely so we had like technical
interview we had our world a little bit
debatable but like we believe that
technical interviews should be most
similar to what the person will do in
the day-to-day mm-hmm
and should test the the knowledge that
they would most have to do most
decisions with so we built like this
interview that actually they had to
build like a small credit card
authorizer which like a part of it and
we could it was the same interview for
someone junior someone senior the only
difference was how well they did the
architecture and like the edge cases
based on how generally understand era
like if they were a senior they knew
like everything that wouldn't go wrong
and they would build it or point it out
if they didn't have time and if they
were junior they would build a simple
version of it and we could tell based on
that but then I think the hard part was
the selling right like how do you sell
and get these people across the line and
I think that for the first 10 it was
really hard and we just like people join
who believed in the team and believed in
the mission and we never made
compensation a problem we're always very
generous with the initial packages so we
we were like so we have this really
different offer mechanism mm-hmm that
and this is until today everyone that
joined the company went yes can you talk
about that a little bit it is different
and it's very intriguing yeah we we call
it a pre offer not an offer mm-hmm which
we say hey if compensation wasn't an
issue you have all these companies you
can join would this be the company would
join
and let's discuss that until you tell me
that this is the common you would join
if comprehension was solved like I'm not
gonna show you an offer
mm-hm and that made the person get over
the mental decision of like this is a
company I want to join and this is why
it's better and then we always give a
super generous offer it's not like we've
been lowball them you know we always
gave them a great offer and they were
always like very few times we hadn't
negotiated usually it was like above
their expectations and then they joined
but we we've never had someone that
after they accepted a P offer they
didn't come because of compensation we
could always find a middle ground in
compensation I think there are a couple
of other YC startups that actually use a
similar approach but the large majority
doesn't yeah it's definitely um
sometimes humbling example sometimes say
no to you before even seeing the offer
yeah like I'm glad that that happened
yeah because they should go to the
company that they believe more mm-hmm
right and then we were evaluating to see
what was their problem maybe they
weren't interested in the domain maybe
they didn't believe as much like
whatever it is we try to learn from it
but we know that it was about the
company not about a comp you know like
all those imagine if they had come yeah
calm yeah
what problem would that be you know yeah
one of the other things I've noticed
especially working with you guys closely
is both you and Petra do spend a lot of
time on recruiting and you know and
first-time founders have seen generally
you know don't do that especially in the
early days and then wait too long before
they actually refocus their attention on
recruiting can you talk a little bit
about why you guys do that and you guys
do it pretty well which is like you
spend a lot of time recruiting and also
talk about how much time you spend a
coating yeah so we spend probably thirty
five to forty percent of our time
recruiting and that nothing honest it
that doesn't mean sourcing by the way
yeah we think we really like our I think
our well we haven't hire recruiter until
now but we had recruiters outsource
working for us I think since we were
like four people mm-hmm and we were big
for like where we don't mind payment
he's if it's success based only we don't
like paying fees that like we have to
pay before but like if it's success base
we think it's worth it
and we we think that we read this in
that google book I think that Irish
Schmidt wrote that like don't let the
urgence you have to hire like reduce the
bar of the people mm-hmm and we've done
that so many times and back in the day
because like you always say hey I'm just
gonna hire someone later I don't need
that person now what this person's like
they're gonna come and they're gonna do
what like there's all these arguments in
the end of the day we just believe that
to find the best people just have to
interview more people like that's just
what you have to do and if you really
need them in like a month or two you'll
just won't interview that many people
because you'll just like okay I kind of
you this person because that's gonna
make mm-hmm and I think it's like a lot
of times if you do need that person that
month and it can make or break the
business you should hire them but we
just don't want to be in that position
mm-hmm so that's why we spend a ton of
our time meeting a lot of people and
recruiting and all that so can you talk
about after you went through YC in
winter 17 what was sort of your
fundraising history both angels your CDs
a and CDs be yeah so we a series a kinda
together for seed round in March last
year and that was I think seven and a
half million dollar round led by a fund
called ribbit that was after YC and we I
remember we closed that round the
morning of demo day so it was very
timely and that was when Peter and max
came in and like a lot of other
investors and then we we did in fund
raise I have a little bit of different
opinion fundraising a lot of people I
think you should build relationship of
VCS over time instead of just doing a
fundraising process and then like
stopping mm-hmm
because I think that if you're gonna add
someone to your life for like 10 years
20 years like you might as well know
them outside of fundraising process yeah
right so we did actively meet a bunch of
people and like start having even a week
after if any fundraising we kept taking
the meetings and like say hey we're not
friends but I would love to like getting
to know the partner I think I would love
to get to know you and like then we met
them to read like every three months or
so and when
the became around that we went to view
guys we already knew like everyone we
wanted to talk to because we already
knew people we liked and that treat is
super well and people that we didn't
like that Dimitri too super well mm-hmm
and then it was like a really fast
process and because of that yeah and I
think one thing I would add there this
is where I think it's different for a
friend tech and maybe certain select
startups because you know even though
you guys are not launching publicly
until now I think the key difference is
you know you were working on building
the tech stack the FinTech stack and
also you had at least more than hundred
pilot customers right so it was already
being used by quite a few startups and
you know it's very similar to if you
look at the stripe of the gussto story
as well you know you can't there's no
room for errors in a payroll product you
know it has the your paycheck has to
come and so you know güstrow sort of did
the same thing which is like almost for
the first 15 months they didn't publicly
launch but that doesn't mean they
weren't testing the product our
customers right and so that's sort of
what you guys were focusing during those
12 15 months is what it takes to launch
it scale by working with a few select
startups exactly and I'm not say we're
not gonna have bugs but we spend a lot
of time trying to raise the possibility
of oh yeah because you're okay if like
your restaurant app doesn't work right
but yeah not okay if like you're buying
a dinner for a client your car doesn't
go true like how pissed at you right
yeah that's true and also like if the
payments don't happen on diamonds yeah
yeah yeah so I think that's an important
distinction for anybody who's working in
front deck or a product where you know
you don't have as much room for error
and so you know it comes down really to
found a market fit and then product
market fit and then seeing exhaustion
and the other thing that's also true is
for both gussto stripe and oz which is
different from a lot of companies is
that everyone needs of version of you
everyone needs a version of payroll
everyone needs a version of payment
processing and everyone needs a version
of corporate credit cards you you use
has to be better than the other guys
which is a very different than like I
don't know if I need this
product optimize my lead or whatever
like you know there's like it's a little
bit different concept when you're
rebuilding something that already exists
in a better way to everybody has to get
one in or when you're creating a new
market or when you're like just building
something better or something that
already exists yeah it's different set
of challenges and different so yeah and
the stack is pretty complex yeah right
if you want to have to build it from
scratch
so you've this is your second fin tech
startup pretty much right so and there
are lots of you know founders trying to
build something new in the FinTech space
especially these days I mean we can see
that even in the volume of applications
that YC is getting what advice do you
have for someone who is a new founder
trying to build a fin tech startup so be
super transparent on it is I don't think
we could have build Brax if you were
have not build a fence tech started
before
mm-hmm or at least worked at an earlier
stage fin tech star before because a big
part of it is that when you get to a
like a meeting of a bank like you know
what you're talking about like you know
how things work you have credibility we
want to be able to raise the size rounds
we raised without like having that so I
would either work in a company in an
early-stage fin tech company that you
think it's successful or I would like
yeah well I started a company that work
but if Brazil is like a way less
competitive market right like so if
maybe you're International try to start
something in your country and then after
moved to the US I think in here in the
US it's really really hard to do and I
really admire people that had done it
from the first time and and got it right
like Patrick and John yeah yeah but I
don't think I mean I personally could
have done it without it so I think like
maybe joining would be a good idea and
for example like people who join put
army like two of them started fin tech
companies are doing really well in
Brazil because they were able to get and
I'm pretty sure there's probably some
stripe alums that are starting from tech
companies that are gonna do phenomenally
well
what is difficult you think because of
which having working at a early stage
FinTech startup or things that you learn
from Pagar like what what are what are
things that you think you will get core
skills by working at a FinTech early
startup that you don't have when you're
starting you I think that there is a few
things one understanding how financial
systems work so if you're an engineer
understanding how to build financial
systems is different than building like
a regular like a pour database there's a
lot of extra constrains etc second
there's just like knowledge about the
market how it works and that you can
learn but it becomes really like to
innovation within payments is a deep
understanding of the constraints and a
deep understanding of how to like go
around those constraints can you give an
example
so someone coming into the FinTech
market for example and starting to build
bricks what people would say would be
hey what do you do is you go and you
hire this like company call a processor
and this processor today takes care of
like all these things for you and
they're really good and you go to talk
to the processor and you're really good
they sell it they do all these things
like perfect like everyone does does
this seems to be a really good system
just gonna be an app no a mobile app on
top of this and it's gonna be great
right and that's the common sense if you
tell someone hey I'm gonna build my own
processing stack from scratch people
will laugh at you they're gonna be like
no man you're crazy if you're asked
anyone from any bang they're gonna know
that's impossible that's like super hard
like you won't be able to do that and
the thing is is that it is really hard
but it's doable you know and if you
don't do it you're gonna be have a lot
of constraints and if you haven't done
it before if you haven't seen the system
that worked from scratch before and how
that worked and why it's complicated
it's actually is really hard to build
one from scratch so in terms of for
example engineering is something or the
other example is so people tell you Oh
Kate YC which is like the way you have
to get to New York customer right for
regulation purposes this is the way you
have to do it you have to collect these
documents etcetera etcetera but if you
actually go read the law itself it gives
you a lot of flexibility in the way you
collect information the way we're out
the validate information
and if you're not aware of like how can
you go read that law understand how that
works and apply it in that context and
then how do you sell the bank that that
is a good thing yeah
like you won't be able to get away with
it right it's not leaking create your
inform and that's it so I think just
like being able to navigate all those
thing is not like you have infinite
amount of shots like you you have like
one or two shots you have to get this
thing right to have to have learned it
from somewhere before so it's a
combination of knowing the regulatory
requirements understanding the
complexity behind the financial systems
in the tech stack and knowing that just
plastering something on the top is not
gonna work exactly and giving and having
the credibility for people to believe
that you know that because you might
know yeah but if nobody believes that
you know because you've never done it
yeah then it's gonna be really hard
that's fair that's fair and for you guys
in the US for sure
it's definitely harder coming from
Brazil but the fact that you build Pagar
at me helps you yeah mm-hmm and what
does bricks exactly do today right
you're you obviously are just going to
launch so what is the value proposition
for a start-up founder on why they
should use Brax over other options
it sounds like getting a card is
difficult but beyond getting a card like
what are the things bricks actually does
yeah for sure
um so the we have basically have two
things going very quickly the first one
is you can get a card like from sign-up
to working virtual credit card so our
credit card number to actually work and
you can news online in like four minutes
four minutes yeah okay so from Sun so
all the way from putting the entire
information to getting a card like
literally same day for a minute exactly
exactly and so that was one and today
we're the only corporate card it doesn't
require any kind of personal guarantee
your security deposit or anything like
that like we underwrite 100% of the
company and we give you a limit that's
many times higher than the most of the
banks would give and like you can get in
four minutes
so that's like one part of it and the
second part is that we automate a bunch
of expense management stuff that you
would have to do manually and we just do
all that for you and a bun
of expense management software can't do
because they're not a credit card to
have to interact with the credit card so
we just build it all into the credit
card and you don't have to worry about a
lot of things later later let me touch
on the first point because I think that
is a big value proposition especially to
get the card pretty much in four minutes
and is that something the founders get
the entire company gets like how does
how does that work well the founder
finally just signed up gets that first
one and they they can invite anyone
their company and that's like yeah I'm
literally to fill in username password
and delivery address yeah and then they
all instantly get a virtual credit card
that works and they can set limits to
them so not everybody has access to all
the corporate credit cards you can give
people a card of like $200 limits per
person or whatever got it and how are
you able to under I do the KYC checks
that quickly like what is different
about the Breck stack that helps you do
that so this is one of the things that
we feel very strongly about is when
you're rebuilding like when you want to
disrupt like for example I don't like
disrupts like a road mm-hmm fancy word
but redefining the experience yeah when
we're redefining the experience there's
no way you can just build an app on top
of an existing thing or building like a
dashboard and top of an existing
financial product like we believe you
have to actually rebuild the financial
product mm-hmm so that's like one of the
things that we feel very strongly about
and when we started brest we were like
okay we're not gonna be like some sort
of Legion for a existing bang and they
do everything we're gonna do everything
from scratch so in terms of underwriting
we went and we rebuild a whole
underwriting concept and instead of
looking at financial history we look at
cash right like we look at how much
investors actually invested in that
company when they're right based on that
and the average burn areas and all of
that which is something that it's
specific for startups at this point
mm-hmm but it allows us to do it very
quickly right so in terms of key YC we
just use modern methods to evaluate who
you are and what you do right like we
use modern tools to not have to make you
go to a branch and sign something
physically like we have better to call
to have you sign something digitally so
and the reason banks don't do that
because they all rely and these third
party like old vendors that do
everything for them and they don't
implement this new technology so we
basically just like rebuild the entire
system in the entire stack from scratch
which allowed us to do these things and
it's that's the reason why you waited
for launching because it's not you know
most YC startups launch after demo day
right and you guys graduated and went to
17 but you're pretty much launching in
mid 2018 like what was sort of holding
you up from launching it's exactly that
we didn't go to the trash like hey let's
do something like didn't just launch in
and have like whatever experience the
bank gave us you know like we want to
build something right and we had to take
the time to basically rebuild all these
systems from scratch like we had to
build a general ledger inside the
company that controls all the balances
so we don't lose money but those kind of
things are really hard to build and the
three months of YC and we believe that
why a lot of FinTech startups fail is
because they don't take control over the
full experience and they they're always
limited by the bank partner doesn't want
to do this or the bag partners want to
do that or this this old system does one
do this we're like we're not gonna deal
with it is we're just gonna rebuild
everything from scratch and launch about
yeah and one other thing I know we've
talked about in the past but I think
it'll be helpful for you know our
founder audiences like there's lots of
lessons and learnings you have from
Pagar taught me that you sort of brought
in at Breck's
can use talk about especially setting up
the process right because I know that's
something you've felt very strongly
about when you're launching breaks and
it's sort of how the product has been
built to help the customer yeah so the
story on this is we when we start plug
our net we didn't know this thing called
a county existed like we didn't know it
was a thing well you were 15 and 16 yeah
and they're like oh yeah okay give me
your your P&L I was like what's a piano
just like how much your process
I just built a spreadsheet hey this how
much cash we've had this how much we
burn right yeah you're like no I want to
piano you're like okay and then pager
night we literally went study accounting
and literally mm-hmm like did our books
from scratch for three entire months
because we had absolutely no accounting
right and that was like was a great
learning experience but it took a lot of
time and energy and then when I we got
to Briggs were like okay we're not gonna
have this problem we're gonna have our
accounting look really good from the
first day we're gonna have like our
expense management systems and like all
these things like really well setup from
the first day because if you know what
you're doing it takes a day to set up
everything right is like not that big of
a deal and it's so much dividends later
on because like one thing that's really
important to be able to control your
business like know how much you're
spending and that doesn't mean cash burn
like yeah losses and spend cash burn
like are very different things know how
much that you're actually making right
no one what you're spending is it the
categories the vendor is like all of
that and that's a pain you ask to do
right if you're gonna do it manually
with the existing systems like I know
it's really in a way and that's why like
a lot of times founders just like don't
do it and say hey when I raise my series
there when I raise my series B I'll just
pay someone to do it but like it's not a
type of thing also that you can throw
money in a problem and then it's
magically solved yeah right like you're
gonna have to spend your time on this
and you just spend a day in the
beginning setting these things up right
like you won't have to deal with it in
the future and it's like pay so much
dividends mm-hmm so I think that's one
of the lessons we just like build the
financial part of the company like right
from day one day one so let's talk about
the second element of your product
because the first element is the founder
signs up you're making it real easy for
them to get access to card as well as a
certain credit limit because they have
some cash in the bank they've raised
from credible investors so how what
exactly does Drex do to help set the
process of accounting right for that so
basically a few things the first one is
we think it's important for our company
to know how much they spend on a vendor
mm-hmm on a vendor base how many
surrenders like it oh yes AWS Google etc
yeah today the status quo is you know
how much everything you paid through ace
why're you kind of know what you're
spending on but everything that you
spent on card you have no idea right you
just credit card $100,000 I have no idea
what's in there and then you have to get
consolidate all these like extra reports
from all these different services to
know how much you're spending right we
actually give you a report and upload to
your accounting system report how much
you're spending by vendor which is not
possible in the current cards today
the second thing is that like keeping
track of receipts is something that if
you don't enforce the policy from day
one people just won't do it in the
future
and you're gonna have problems with that
when you have to get an audit or like
people are now I have like all these
expenses etc so we just created a super
easy way they can just like text a
receipt to us and that's it we
automatically match it to a transaction
and no we don't have humans going
manually doing it it's actually
automatic and the reason we could
automate this versus other companies
cutting is because we're both the credit
card and we had to receipt so matching
your receipts to a transaction is that
way is your job in reading the receipt
and figuring out everything about it
yeah so that's like the second thing
that we do that it's super useful and
then we do all these things like we
categorize everything right like because
the automatic categorization not without
getting too technical on payments but
like the automatic characterization from
credit cards they trust this thing
called MCCS and that's always wrong
because so like for example uber a lot
of times comes it's like Car Rental
right and you don't want rubriz and your
car rent all you want is like taxi right
yeah so we redo that in the right way
there's like about new things we do that
you just don't have to worry about it
and we use it for ourselves and it's
like we literally have no trouble of
accounting we have our books - every day
it's like it's beautiful that's pretty
awesome that sounds great and I know
even though you are launching publicly
only now you have been piloting your
product for a while can you talk a
little bit about your customers what
types of customers use your product is
this really early-stage startups or a
later stage and how do the different use
cases work so we have two use cases um
we're usually on the earlier stage where
people's first card and they basically
you sign up for us to switch to us
because we're super easy to get we deal
with all these accounting things that
they they don't have
to deal with and you can just like don't
not worry about it and like not have the
hassle of doing it and we have like um
like a lot of the ryc batch uses it in
the following YC batch of a bunch of
people use it so we got we definitely
use all the YC strategies getting a lot
of YC companies and we're very very
happy about that and the other thing is
like for companies that's over a certain
size we have another set of
functionality that allows them to have
better controls and like policies and
stuff like that so we got companies like
firm or sofa or color genomics to use
Breck's
because they when they get bigger they
start having problems with their current
corporate card so we help them add
better controls and better reporting and
like a lot of larger company kind of
functionality and that allows us to
scale with the company so yeah we're
pretty sure if like if someone starts
with Braxley can scale all the way with
us yeah versus having to migrate to a
different solution like yeah yeah one of
the things I know like when we were
working together on like talking to some
of the growth stage companies their
bigger pain points was like with
controls and especially as the employee
base expands like how do you know what's
the spend on expenses versus accounts
payables and so on
yeah and so you know that was something
that's still a pain point that's not
solved so why do you think I mean why do
you think this is getting solved now why
didn't it get saw was this not a problem
10 years ago I think that b2b ping b2b
with cards has grown a lot over the last
five years so if you think about like
the largest company in the world their
main way to receive money is card right
like Microsoft Google Facebook you pay
all your facebook ads of card until
you're really really big and you could
still pay of carpets it's discussion for
another point um and so I think that
before like hard was just 14 e card was
something that you Paley you gave your
employees for travel for
paying Cavs here and there but now card
is becoming this like procurement way of
paying so like way to pay like your
actual big expenses like a lot of
offices are starting to take card like
we work right like you can literally pay
your card so now it's getting to it was
always big but now it's growing really
really fast and demand the new
technology in the space to be able to
scale to the company so it doesn't
happen then oh now I agree and I have to
move everything off of card and into
invoices right so I think that changed
like over the last five years yeah and I
also think with the new tech stack and
the flexibility like it's kind of absurd
that you have a controller asset limit
for the entire was this is there
something you can do more flexible at an
employee level yeah right for the
company to better manage expenses and
especially startups where the cash born
really fluctuates exactly months to
months
so exactly well thank you so much Henry
cave for joining us today I'm sure that
a lot of people probably really enjoyed
the discussion especially from how to
start a fin tech startup thank you very
much
you